thomas bonsoir malgré le rétropédalage
des communicants de la maison blanche
les propos de joe biden ont fait réagir
les autorités chinoises
mais on peut dire que la sortie
médiatique de joe biden a relancé les
tensions avec pékin cela s'est donc
produit lors d'un exercice de
communication du locataire de la maison
blanche qui a eu lieu ce jeudi soir joe
biden face à des citoyens américains le
tout retransmis sur la chaîne de
télévision cnn et puis donc il y a eu
cette question de la part d'un des
participants questions sur taïwan mais
plus généralement sur la chine alors joe
biden a d'abord affirmé que les états
unis avaient l'armé la plus puissante du
monde et il a donc répondu par
l'affirmative à la question de savoir si
les états unis à défendre est taiwan en
cas d'attaqué de la chine alors 2 puis à
la maison blanche tente de modérer
d'atténuer quelque peu les propos du
président américain en expliquant qu'il
n'y a pas de changement dans la
politique américaine à l'égard de taïwan
il ya aussi eu les déclarations ce
vendredi du secrétaire américain à la
défense lloyd austin qui est lui aussi
pondère en expliquant qu'il ne veut pas
se prononcer sur d'hypothétiques actions
de la chine mais dans le même temps il
réaffirme la position très stricte des
états unis à l'égard de taiwan écouté
personne ne veut en venir aux mains pour
une question de passage certainement pas
le président d'haydn et il n'y a aucune
raison pour que cela se produise vous
nous avez entendu le dire à plusieurs
reprises et je le répète elle nous
restons attachés à notre politique d'une
seule chine conformément à la loi sur
les relations avec taiwan et aux trois
assurances des six communiqué comme nous
l'avons fait au cours de plusieurs
administrations et nous continuerons à
aider taiwan à se doter des capacités
dont elle a besoin pour se défendre et
nous resterons donc concentrés sur ces
points
alors évidemment ses prises de position
du côté américain ne sont pas vraiment
du goût des autorités chinoises on
rappelle que pékin considère taïwan
comme faisant partie
son territoire les autorités chinoises
qui se réfèrent aussi aux accords qui
sont en vigueur pour régir les relations
diplomatiques entre washington et taipei
on appelle cela une la stratégie une
stratégie un petit peu floue à des états
unis à l'égard de taiwan depuis de
nombreuses années une stratégie qui
semble donc avoir été remises quelque
peu en question par joe biden lors de
ses déclarations jeudi écoutez la
réaction de la diplomatie chinoise
sur les questions liées à ses intérêts
fondamentaux comme sa souveraineté son
intégrité territoriale la chine ne
laissera aucune place au compromis
personne ne doit sous-estimer la
détermination inébranlable la volonté la
forte capacité du peuple chinois à
défendre sa souveraineté son intégrité
territoriale ne vous opposez pas aux 1
milliard 400 millions de chinois
alors cet épisode diplomatique
intervient dans un contexte de tensions
grandissantes entre pékin et washington
une opposition commercial géostratégique
mais c'est vrai que la question de
taiwan pour un certain nombre
d'observateurs pourrait constituer un
risque d'opposition armé entre la chine
et les états unis et il faut noter que
le choix du nouvel ambassadeur américain
en chine par joe biden ne risque pas
d'atténuer ces tensions puisque ce
dernier a été auditionné cette semaine
au sénat il a expliqué qu'il était
favorable au fait que les états unis
vendent encore davantage d'armes à
destination de taïwan alors malgré les
déclarations ce jeudi de joe biden qui a
expliqué ne pas vouloir instaurer une
nouvelle guerre froide entre les états
unis et la chine force est de constater
que les différentes prises de position
américaine ces dernières semaines semble
aller tout droit vers cette direction
merci beaucoup ton abonnés en directeur
de washington